starting in business in 2019 is daunting
especially when there's so many web
sites out there that are trying to trick
you and take your hard-earned money
that's why today we're gonna start a
business in under five minutes what's
going on guys my name is David Tom edge
from welcome back to the channel today
we're gonna be talking about how to
start a business in Australia in 2019
before you're ready to call yourself an
official business in Australia there are
four things that you need to achieve
before you click off this video one you
need to set up your tax file number two
you're going to want to have a business
name registered three you're gonna need
an Australian business number set up or
potentially an ACN not an AVM and four
you're gonna need a domain name if you
want to compete you 2019 chances are if
you've clicked on this video you
probably already have an australian tax
file number setup which is great you can
skip straight step two I'm gonna link it
right here that's the time stamp if you
want to check it out however if you
don't have me show the tax part number
set up I'm gonna link it down below in
the description to make it easy for you
guys because there's plenty of companies
out there that are trying to take your
money away from you and get you to click
on different links and try to get you
through these different avenues if your
insurance citizen it's actually very
easy to apply for a tax file number
basically all you have to do is go to
the link in the description below click
the link open their online form fill it
out and take it to your nearest
Australia Post before you go to the
Australian post office though make sure
you also book an interview online once
you've booked this interview it's
basically just saying to the post office
people that you're coming down to prove
that you are who you say you are you're
also gonna need to take 100 points of ID
which means the driver's license
passport and birth certificate anything
along those lines that has your name
your date of birth and your current
living address once you apply for tax
part number it can actually take a
little bit of time to arrive and get
processed it can take anywhere between 7
& 30 days if not longer depending on the
backlog that the government has at the
time but once you've received your tax
file number you're ready to register an
Australian business name and also apply
for your stray lien business number now
something I've learned over the years is
make sure that when you
thinking of a business name and checking
out the availability on the show and
government website you also check that
business name that gets the domain name
because the last thing you want to have
is one business name and then a
completely different domain it's gonna
throw all your customers off and it's
going to be really tricky for people to
find you on Google and other search
platforms which at the end of the day is
one of your most effective selling
points in the description below I'm also
going to link the ato government website
that lets you check different business
names and different company names to see
if it's available for you to register
your name today well it's the best place
I've found to check for domains it's
actually crazy domains this video isn't
sponsored in any way shape or form it's
just one website that I found to be very
easy and user-friendly and they've
actually got some pretty decent prices
too which makes it an added benefit the
ATO is actually simplified this process
since the last time I registered one of
my businesses but thankfully they've
made registering a business name and
registering for an ABN or an ACN on the
exact same website so it's just one form
and one online lodgement that you have
to do now if you're still thinking
what's the difference between a B and a
CN well the difference is actually quite
simple if you're holding an ABN number
chances are you're a sole trader
somebody that doesn't have any employees
and doesn't have a large company
structure whereas an ACN is a company
name and it is a company structure an
ABN is cheap and effective to set up and
only costs 50 to $100 a year to keep
that running whilst an ACN costs upwards
of $1,000 to set up and is quite
labor-intensive sometimes you need to
get your accountants involved and your
tax agents involved and all sorts of
different lawyers just to get that
structure going so if you are a one-man
team and you're just starting your
business for the first time I personally
recommend going straight to a sole
trader and only registering an ABN for
the time being linking your company or
your new company to your tax file number
and having that interlaced between two
once you've applied for your ABN and
you're a lien business name I recommend
going ahead and buying that domain name
straightaway as well just in case
somebody swoops in and takes it from you
before you get the approved application
now if you're applying for a provocative
or a derogatory term chances are it's
gonna get denied by the Australian
Government and
waste 20 30 bucks in that domain name so
if you are starting a business with a
business name that's potentially a
little bit ambiguous maybe hold off on
that domain name until you receive your
application from the Australian
government and it's all good to go and
there you have it guys the basic steps
starting a brand new business in
Australia and 2019 in under five minutes
if you enjoy this video make sure you
smash that subscribe button 20-19 style
and I'll see you next Monday